le festival a commencé lundi et au fil
des jours les fresques que se dévoilent
d'eau publics au pied de ce bâtiment de
12 m 2 aux passants et conducteurs ont
tous les yeux levés
ben c'est bien c'est bien peu de
couleurs à la ville ce que quand tu vois
les bâtiments qui sont très fatigués
donc ça met un peu de couleurs sa laine
hinse
en tout cas tout le monde s'arrête et
regarde oui parce qu'elle est assez
impressionnante quand même celle là
qu'il soit 10,6 du canada de puerto rico
du mexique ou d'ukraine
nous artistes avaient carte blanche pour
donner vie à des murs anonyme leur
travail attise la curiosité invite les
passants à voir la ville autrement ça
permet aux à tout le monde de lever les
yeux vers les façades
tous ces immeubles ces magnifiques
immeubles avec les balcons qui
disparaissent au fur et à mesure qu'ils
tombent en ruine
eh bien peut-être que ça va donner une
autre façon de regarder cette ville avec
une architecture que je trouve
magnifique mais qui tombe en décrépitude
en fait rue lazare carnot tout ce pâté
de maison vient en effet d'être rasée
mais celui où bien des familles ont vécu
est une inspiration pour cet artiste
californien
ça m'inspire énormément de se peindre je
préfère ces environnements quand tout
est rasé c'est une opportunité pour
quelque chose de nouveau mais pour moi
c'est très beau mais aussi on ressemble
plus d'intimité
lorsque l'on casse des murs vous pouvez
voir dans les maisons il ya des
souvenirs ici il ya une histoire
alors vous imaginez ce qu'il ya eu ici
et vous avez une toile blanche pour
quelque chose de nouveau pour ce
festival le thème imposé et l'homme et
la nature d'une fresque à l'autre bien
sûr les styles diffèrent et plaisent
plus ou moins aux passants mais
l'important est ailleurs pour cet
événement déjà organisé sur plusieurs
continents le but est d'inviter l'art
dans notre quotidien
les artistes ont des styles différents
des démarches artistiques différentes
qui on les laisse s'exprimer ça fait
partie de la liberté d'expression tout
est possible lassé des artistes qui
viennent de l'extérieur mais qui
encourage ses des artistes locaux avec
leur première expérience donc c'est
vraiment un échange et
et aussi de donner un souffle nouveau à
l'art mural qui est pas vraiment
représenté en martinique
donc ça permet aussi de donner à une
perspective à quant à l'art mural ici
les artistes rangent leurs pinceaux
lundi et repartent vers de nouvelles
aventures
le travail réalisé sur 1500 mètres carré
de mur foyalais sera durable ou bien
éphémère en fonction des mutations de la
ville